did you have any type of premonition or
feeling that the blacklist would be so
well-received what was it again
something that you were very passionate
about finding out more it it was
something that fascinated me and because
I came into Hollywood and experienced
what was the tail end of the of the
people who had been blacklisted I
studied with an amazing wonderful acting
teacher named Jeff quarry who had been
blacklisted he was an actor who had been
blacklisted and I didn't know much about
the blacklist but all his students knew
that the only reason that Jeff was
teaching was because he was blacklisted
because otherwise he would have been
such a working actor that none of us
would have had the benefit of his gifts
and so there was a kind of an interest
for me because of that and then I met a
woman who told me that her husband had
been blacklisted and she started telling
me stories about the blacklist and
suddenly I was hearing names that I was
dealing with in Hollywood as an actress
these were people that I had auditioned
for people that I had read for you know
that I had worked for and I thought wow
this is all like been dusted under the
rug somewhere nobody nobody talks about
this now and so I said are any of these
people still around and she introduced
me to the entire blacklist community and
I found them to be some of the most
wonderful creative smart people and then
I realized as I started delving into
this these people have made some of the
great movies that had influenced my life
as a child and where were they now they
weren't working and movies had taken a
big swing in a very superficial
direction you know the it was the the
age of the beach blanket bingo movie
the the the the Elvis movies and movies
had just gone into a very superficial
place at that time and as an actress I
had wondered you know where were all
these great parts like these women who
had had great parts in these movies well
they weren't written anymore and the
writers who wrote them word around
anymore
but they were alive but they couldn't
work and so that became a very
interesting subject matter for me and
again to the credit of AFI I took my
camera equipment and I went out and shot
an interview with this one woman and
submitted it to AFI and they gave me a
grant to start the movie
so that's how the blacklist got off the
ground so it sounds like similar
parallel with the girls in the band
because you dipped your toe in the water
I became very intrigued with the subject
exactly starts with one interview yeah
yeah do you think any type of blacklist
exists today maybe for different reasons
I don't really know that I keep seeing
things in in the papers a saying
blacklist but it has some other kind of
meaning it doesn't have the same kind of
meaning as what was happening in the in
the 40s and the 50s in this country
because that was political that was
government inspired whatever blacklist
there is now that's internecine warfare
inside of studios with agents and stars
and stuff like that
and it doesn't have the gravitas of what
happened in the forties and fifties yeah
you were nominated for an Emmy Award yes
correct
was that a goal it just happened because
you were so passionate about the film
the interviews shown on screen you know
while you're making these things it
somewhere in the back of your mind
you're hoping you'll get recognition for
them and a lot of people were saying to
me oh you're gonna get nominated for
this I know you're going to get nom
for this and I always kind of put that
into a nice little compartment on the
side and say oh yeah that would be
really nice if that happened but that's
not why I'm doing it and then six
o'clock in the morning one day my phone
rings friends say okay that's great so
it was great what were some of the
lessons that you took from doing the
block list onto future projects either
pros and cons things you never would do
again or that you would definitely
repeat
well the blacklist project took me ten
years and after I finished it I said you
know I can't do another project now
that's gonna take me ten years I just
need to do something different and so I
went into the commercial world and
worked in all those other jobs that
sustained a career for me and you know
got me into the directors guild and did
a lot of nice things for my career but I
knew that if I got into another so
called passion project that it was gonna
take a lot of years of my life and so I
didn't want to do that for a long time I
did a lot of other documentaries but
they were short quick things mostly for
television mostly documentaries for hire
and it wasn't till this project came
along that I said okay I know what this
is going to take out of me but I'm ready
to do it again
that was a long time
you